keanu reeves is one of the most popular
actors in the world thanks to headlining
popular franchises including the matrix
john wick and bill and ted but his
off-screen behavior has also played a
big role in helping him capture the
hearts of millions of fans throughout
his long career reeves has developed a
reputation for humbleness charitable
gestures and genuine acts of kindness
those endearing characteristics have
earned him a reputation as one of the
nicest human beings working in the film
industry today many of risa's
collaborators over the years have
publicly recounted how much they enjoy
working with him frequently confirming
his gracious disposition in that vein
fellow john wick chapter 3 parabellum
star halle berry has been full of praise
for the action icon following their
collaboration barry particularly took
note of his professionalism on the set
which she explained gave her a newfound
appreciation for the star anyone who has
seen keanu reeves in one of his many
iconic action roles already knows that
he makes epic fight scenes and death
defying stunts look easy the veteran
action star is known for training harder
than most if not all of his co-stars in
many cases halle berry has vouched for
his incredible work ethic on john wick 3
in particular back in 2019 reeves was
memorialized for his contributions to
cinema at the tcl chinese theater in
hollywood and barry was present for the
occasion taking to instagram afterward
barry gushed over her work crush writing
that the occasion was a well-deserved
honor for one of the hardest working
actors she's ever met
in fact barry once revealed that she
enjoys working with reeves so much that
she attempted to keep working on john
wick 3 even after breaking her ribs and
training in an interview with extra she
described feeling particularly motivated
to go above and beyond in order to keep
up with his impressive pace
it was pretty amazing it was a little
terrifying
at first
because he's so damn good and
um i wanted to be on the same level with
him after breaking her ribs while
training for the movie barry initially
kept working not wanting to be taken off
the film at her role recast but she was
grateful to director chad sahelsky for
instead waiting for her injuries to heal
before he resumed filming barry for her
part described the injury she sustained
as a badge of honor it turns out barry
had the opportunity to work with reeves
many years prior to john wick 3 but
passed on the role in a video interview
with mtv news halle berry revealed that
she was once offered a role in speed a
90s thriller starring reeves and sandra
bullock when asked why she didn't sign
on to that film barry self-deprecatingly
explained
yes my stupidity didn't allow no stop
however reeves was quick to defend
barry's decision not to join the cast of
speed after all the script that berry
red didn't yet feature reeves as its
lead and bizarrely the bus didn't even
leave the parking lot with that premise
reeves said he doesn't blame her for
turning down the roll
right we can't leave this parking lot if
we leave this parking lot on the bus it
blows up i mean
of course i don't blame you for like
going
next
by the time she was offered her role in
john wick 3 however reeves was of course
already attached to the project
in fact he was one of the reasons she
accepted barry was already a fan of the
first two john wick films and had
watched some of the videos of reeves
training for his action scenes in those
films i'd seen behind the scenes you
know clips of him and i saw his training
and i heard about it so i knew what i
was signing up for and that's largely
why i wanted to do it but far from barry
being the only fan of her co-stars work
admiration between the two actors is
mutual during a press conference for
john wick 3 barry mentioned that she
just wanted to prove herself worthy of
sharing a room with reeves but reeves
quickly replied oh come on hallie you're
an inspiration while john wick 3 remains
the sole collaboration between the two
of them judging by their mutual respect
for one another more films starring
barry and reeves together very well
could be on the way
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you